this is really the fighter and the kid
come on baby
yeah yeah I I didn't even want to ask
because I was like that's my life
yeah well I live a little bit far away
why don't you move the studio you guys
have bags Manhattan Beach are you yeah
on the ocean that's where we are yeah
are you down there on it yeah it's the
best you're on the ocean we're in this
not on the ocean dude I'll tell you if
you Lay's fine L.A is totally fine yeah
Encinitas Carlsbad area great that
that's the movement
I don't did you get on the bluff out
there
right on Neptune oh forget it it's
unbelievable I like this guy yeah I mess
with that that's where I want to retire
we're gonna do it now sell your watch
and that Porsche outside done I don't
think so man that's a lot of possessions
that's where Canelo lives big
materialistic guy a lot of like your
items uh that's not an insult by the way
no used to be cars was like a childhood
thing the watch was you know I'm not not
uh
you like craftsmanship
he loves like quality stuff hell yeah
dude you like nice stuff I like I just
can't like nice stuff I think once again
all around materialist things like I
don't want to be that guy but you got a
couple nice things yeah it's nice yeah
it bothers me
it bothers me that you have that shiny
Raven that Raven wing
shine to your thick Mane and you hide it
under that [__] hat we all got hats
look at your hair Bubba
I'm not like in the older guys but if
you were given the opportunity kellen's
definitely top ten that's slender film
around I literally picked them up
actually I have to give you a compliment
when I walked out decided to take a
twozie before we started this thing
yeah I did it was here's the worst part
is he walked into the bathroom with me I
just sat there with my my butt cheeks
clenched until he like dude walks up
finally left and he was like talking to
me while I'm sitting there I'm so
uncomfortable it's all things good yeah
yeah I'll see you outside man he's like
yeah your baby you know like the Delta
gun he's talking about the Delta guy yo
I got it it's like a faucet down here
dude let me do this
by the way
what'd you say about me because I'm like
Hey where's Callan as I was walking out
the door I picked him up I grabbed him
yeah and I picked him up and more dense
than I expected there's a difference
there's not a lot of give your stream
however in this in the urinal you need
to go see a doctor
by the way yours goes like a it's like
you're like an Austin Powers when he
gets out of the cryo chamber yeah
Morgan or Delta buddy yesterday I'm
peeing he said the same [__] thing
yesterday he said same thing he goes I
haven't probably prostate I go I'm
[__] peeing it's taking me a little
longer it's a weak stream brother you
got something I need to go you need to
get three Knuckles deep that's right
that's two for two yeah three Knuckles
you have to make sure I'm sure it's flat
back anymore they take a blood test no
they put your fingers
and he goes like this
oh instead of using KY
and he does that now me and me and will
piss like Super Soakers man no bro I I
don't know it's a long dribble sometimes
I'm saying that I'm like come on oh yeah
I went home about that she's like he's
got to actually go see a doctor yeah
yeah I want to go hit one of them
colonics where they get the little tubes
yeah hell yes suck all that stuff out
yes yeah you guys have problems pooing
no it's just helpful no no no yeah
absolutely you do no not [__] I
promise you used to you do dude you play
in the league homie
playing the league you get in the
[__] game like I have Chase you got
to work through some injuries you're
taking Toradol you're taking Tramadol
you're gonna mess up your digestive
diclofenac yeah there's a phrase in the
locker room two dicks a day keep the
doctor away the little diclofen axles
little dicks you take two of those what
are those
anti-inflammatory they're
anti-inflammatories and literally three
days into Camp the boys are like that's
our [__] new message
you're taking that much every day every
single day every day gone on game day
it's uh she remembers your Liberty going
yeah but there's books with your gut
health and everything like now that I'm
obviously in a different situation
I'm all trying to get my health right
we're talking this Dr lion person she's
all time but like
I literally have to take magnesium
otherwise that's three days before I
think I should something it's like that
but did you have fun right
is worth it oh yeah that's not [__] on
the league yeah and it was and it was
great I did fly economy here but I had a
[__] blast I had a [__] that makes me
sad
that might just be good with money
though me yeah yeah or it's gotten so
bad
a little bit
Taylor's got money yeah I'm aware uh
offensive tactical I saw you were with
uh Rogan a fight companion yep and he
obviously probably told you about the
gambling situation with Dana did he tell
you about that yeah he told me Dana
Gamble's big and you were playing with
his money no that's when I thought
that's where I didn't like I saw the
clip and I didn't like the way he put it
people thought it was Dana's money was
your money that's what I was like and I
just assume oh Taylor's balls there's
letting Dana gamble [__] thousands
hundreds of thousands of dollars dude
and it's so we met Dana in February
during the Super Bowl week and he's like
he does his power slap thing and I know
I want to talk to you no I want to talk
to you about that we will let's show
he's going to be in the video game sure
sure one most downloaded app by the way
Powers up we can hit it all we want yeah
it does numb dude
we'll get to power slap
we can talk about that in a second yeah
we will so he's like you should come out
for powerslide the first parasites March
11th we'll actually be out there [__]
Dana White wants to come out absolutely
when I go to Vegas I usually stay at the
Aria it's Where The Boys stay when we go
on online trips and stuff like that and
I do a big credit line the reason why I
do a big credit line is they give me a
next room they think I'm gonna gamble
jokes on them I hardly gamble at all I
sit at the boys play I don't know we
call it run the ball you put like 100
chip down let's [__] see how this
goes we just have a good time have a
couple drinks we go to UFC Apex area
we're getting ready to do all that stuff
it's awesome and I tell Dan about the
credit line his eyes light up like the
fourth of [__] July and he's like you
and me tonight we're gambling I'm like
oh [__] and I I'm like I'm nervous and
then during the day like hasbula is
there Mark Wahlberg's there I can't even
take the time to appreciate their
presence I'm so worried about gambling
with Dana it's a lot of money dude and
we go to the Red Rock Casino which is
like 25 minutes
it is the best casino in all of Las
Vegas by far we go there this guy named
Joe's there he's you know black dude
shaved head perfect beard shakes my hand
he's like right with me Mr lawn blah
blah we go into the High Roller room I'm
like okay cool it's a lot of it's a hot
like brightly lit very nice then we go
into a separate door which is a private
private room behind the High Roller room
which is where Dana is and Dana and I
since that day I've been gambling once a
month in Vegas and I literally have won
every single time I go because at the
same time well trust me it's a strategy
this story has a bad ending
no the story's not over still it's
always still being written but now we're
in a fight this is where guy loses girl
in movie yes this is where you and Dana
are in a fight no Dana's in a fight Dana
does this three to four times a week oh
he's got and he's yeah
I want to say maybe over I'm talking how
to turn here but maybe over seven
figures and he's like oh look at the top
10 plays going on yeah he doesn't care
he doesn't give a [__] he doesn't care
he's not mad that he loses to the
[__] deal because to him it's
competition like he's like [__] you I'm
taking you can see some of the most dope
like YouTube shorts of him telling about
how he doesn't want your [__] liquor
he's Max betting he's winning two hands
and he's getting the [__] out but he
wins too he wins yeah he wins a lot he
[__] wins you know he got kicked out
of uh I think it was the Mirage it might
have been Palms because he was winning
so much they thought he was cheating
they made him a belt I mean he's banned
everywhere except for right the Duke
dude knows what he's doing and like MGM
what's he what's his game Blackjack okay
and this is what your plan this is what
I'm playing with him and so literally
this is I'm not exaggerating at all
since March I've gone every single month
at least once a month and I will go for
two days Taylor has a problem
the first night sixty thousand dollars a
second night and that's happened last
five months now okay I go to powerslap
this past time okay and I'm thinking I'm
getting to the point now where I'm going
from like massive anxiety attacks like
oh my God I could lose everything too I
don't know if I can lose
cocky as long as I have Dana there's no
[__] problem here I can't believe I'm
sitting like this he's your brother he's
your bunny footage when you have that
kind of recognition of I don't mind I
don't mind it especially you're skinnier
now if you're bigger but you gotta hold
them long Gams up did you see this dude
you see these legs so dude I go there I
go there and uh it's they're having this
big party after in the High Roller room
everyone's kind of gambling and there's
a lot of drunk [__] [__] there
but there's a lot of like your regular
guys that you see on a week to week
basis Dana pulls in high five skill
people looks me in the eyes and he's
like you [__] ready I'm like yeah
let's do this brother let's go we sit
there I was at the tables and I will
shorten the story I was at the tables
from
10 o'clock at night to 5 30 in the
morning no I'm out I'm out no they pump
box because I was losing so bad yeah you
just pumping oxygen it's yeah trying to
get back yeah you're trying to get just
to break even at this yeah just to Break
Even This is my money we're talking
about because I didn't like a big fan of
Joe Rogan massive fan of Joe Rogan got a
chance to hang out with and stuff like
that dude's fantastic he loves you guys
but I didn't he was like he did Gamble's
Dana's Money Dana is like he's a man
holding my hand as I'm gambling my own
money yeah dinner's not that generous
yeah he's not gonna be like here Taylor
here's listen you know generous he's
generous dude I always you guys have to
say that I was down at one point three
hundred thousand dollars
again I was down at one point of this
night this is a week ago three hundred
thousand dollars
now I've told you how much I've won so
there's I can in my second line I can
say oh that's where I'm at I'm down at
some point three thousand dollars there
are Slappy sitting at this table with us
like with 14 15 on the table not hitting
and then Dana goes he gets a 10 and then
he busts obviously then I'm up and I get
the seven he needed [__] like that's
happening all night he leans back to me
he's like hey take 45 minutes just relax
when this starts to slow down a little
bit you and I will go back as he's
making his comeback because he's down
worse than I am he's taking some of his
winnings fifteen thousand dollars in
chips thirty thousand dollars and he's
essentially tossing it to me that's good
so like you go ahead and do this dude
throughout the night he probably gave me
over a hundred thousand dollars in chips
just to save me that's not a human being
he is a fantastic human being he's a
good man and I still [__] lost I
didn't lose 300 000. but I lost lots of
money I lost bat like two points I
haven't had a good night sleeping over a
week I really I swear to God you know
that's how it always is now you're now
you're gonna keep going back out just to
gamble with Dano
yeah I got to do a lot I had to go talk
to myself in the mirror I had to have
like is your wife like hey man once a
month flying to Vegas being up no she's
about it because she's like she's like
um because when we go I'm not just
gambling I'm also doing the powerslide
thing I'm doing content I'm doing stuff
for busting content we're still [__]
we're working it is a job also it's a
lot of money you and you're making that
much it's like how do you not go back I
agree I got a question so you guys are
my boys I love you me and will been
friends for how long I love will I mean
since 1970. before we go back to the 70s
but um when I saw the power slap stuff I
was like oh it's brilliant By Dana what
they're doing having people like you and
the milk boys and everyone like and you
know Nina and being like power stop the
best thing I've ever seen I'm like man
what are they paying those boys what are
they paying those boys to do this
is that the question from the love
that's the question that's a bunch of
heart you don't have to answer that's a
hell of a question no no they need to
answer it's been much once I've been
waiting for them to come and ask us
because here's my thing I'll be very
clear if they hit me up even though I
don't hate on it anymore at first I was
like dude what the hell is he's just
bored and I get it if I had that much
money I'd be bored too so they start the
power slap Fight League but then I
talked through like in person it's way
better in person it's cool to see and I
stopped hanging out because even podcast
has changed unless you're like a
schultzy or like Rogan where people are
watching for three hours this day and
age what we do like let's say this does
whatever 500 000 views by the time we
cut up all the clips we're getting
millions and millions and millions so it
cut down the short form does that make
sense so Dana whoever his team is in him
is like this isn't gonna be a long form
thing like the UFC people are gonna sit
down and watch us for three hours people
aren't going to watch it for 45 minutes
it's just these idiots slapping each
other but we can cut up in short form
and get millions and millions of views
once I saw that I'm like brilliant I'm
in that makes sense my only thing was
when I first saw you guys on board I was
like oh what are they paying those boys
I mean that's a personal question I'm on
record of saying you don't have to
answer that that's easy no it's easy to
pay us
at all it's just content for you guys
it's there's a there's a game there's an
element of content there's an element of
being in the cool kids club
yeah like you you do you do want to get
around other audiences yeah and have
opportunities to meet other people at
these events I'm not hating on anything
to essentially get some relationships
yeah and that's that that's currency
that's real current yeah that that I'm
also a relationship with Dana
and gambling actually getting to know
the guy and that can lead to a lot of
stuff too yeah because I've seen you
guys well I when I saw you guys at the
fights and I see you like so you're
saying hi to Trump and you're saying
you're hanging that puts you guys
oh 45 camera and dude when we met him
powerful dude I was exactly like you
would expect it to be yeah then it goes
over and he goes is Taylor one Will
Compton we meet him he looks at us
couple of big strong handsome men yeah I
was like I [__] thank you you guys
are doing great wow you don't even know
what we're doing great
I'm kind of sitting there and I'm
sitting right I'm sitting right next
trouble I don't know what the [__] to
say I literally just sitting there kind
of like a big dummy and he looks at me
goes you're doing great
amazing he's a powerful dude huh the
energy he's a it's a take politics out
of it just him as a personality [__] bro
when he's sitting like 10 feet away
we're just like yo this man is sitting
right a big guy too big guy himself do
you think you'd have this you'd have the
same energy if Biden was sitting next to
you do you think he's as inner and I'm
not this isn't left or right thing I'm
just saying your energy you know what
you're doing hey it's not political but
you you answer the question
click this with no contacts
being like yeah but it's kind of a [__]
right you guys were like got his ass
dude
no but it's still Biden is the [__]
sitting present you'd still be pretty
excited oh yeah oh no you buy Coley [__]
this is crazy he's mumbling but whatever
so how about this Taylor's one of the
smartest hey bro I don't know you better
relax I told him this story about Biden
so I wanted my good buddy of mine don't
trust anything billionaire billionaire
made about so much money he was nine
billion and uh and he he uh he actually
ran he worked for Biden when he was a
young man and he also ran he was the
vice chairman of his uh uh campaign uh
before this I want to not not he's the
one that made all the sexual allegations
go away no no but he he's he's his name
was Jeffrey he's as smart as [__] guy
he's a guy I check in with when I when
there's a story and I want to check in
with a guy who's a real player and in
those inner circles and I said I said
something effective you know uh he's
just uh binds a blow hard in that dummy
and he looked at me and he said what'd
you say
and I said
what he goes through the phone he said
he was he goes no we're together he goes
he was he's a dummy and he got he's tall
he's about 6'4 he looked at me I felt
uncomfortable he kind of got over me and
he went
he's much smarter than you are and he's
a lot smarter than I am I spent a lot of
time 20 years ago though right well now
he's compromise what I'm saying space
anybody who's been that relevant for
that long right he's got something for
sure
I was a little embarrassed though
because he said he has a stutter which I
didn't know so Biden had a very strong
brain surgery for a long time yeah brain
surgery open brain surgery he did Biden
did facts look it up chin wish you had a
computer yeah facts he's definitely old
now in his cognitive issues there's no
doubt about it dude I wish I was as
cognitive as he was how old is he he's
80. he's kind of crashing it look at
this hey the first article is Joe Biden
as a Survivor two brain surgery two
brains you didn't know this wow wow look
at that
but to go back to it I think here's
where I think everything's a little
[__] up in America is if you have the
opportunity to shake a president's hand
past a present you got to do it you
gotta you shake his head the bottom was
there any I want to be respectful of any
president it's America I'm going to be
respectful to any president I don't care
if I agree with him I'm not he's my
president he was president of my country
I'm going to be respectful as [__] I'm
going to be Mr President nice to meet
you it's not going to say it's wild hell
enough we post a photo though I don't
know how your situation was but I'd have
a couple of actual conversations with
people that I knit like people are upset
right people it's like no you don't get
it it's not I'm not picking a side here
it's Trump bro it's a president it's a
president
not only that like one of the most
influential like billions of another
game ever brilliant business well also
might be the most the biggest political
disrupter the most disruptive figure in
politics maybe Andrew Jackson is a close
rival but I mean historically there's
nobody in his area code were you guys
were you guys a little nervous when he
posts a picture were you like this goes
I don't think so Taylor's like a we
should we should get a photo right and I
was like hell yeah hell yeah I was more
nervous to get a photo of Johnny
Knoxville and I pushed out like a [__]
dude God and I hated that bro oh I love
John I got super high one night and kind
of broke this whole thing down yeah
because I got like a mental thing when I
meet somebody that I'm a fan of
where I like
if I go up to you and I'm like hey I'm a
fan of you let me get a picture with you
let me talk about you now all of a
sudden I've put you here and me here the
the part of us ever becoming friends is
now going to be an issue yeah so I had
like this that's also because you're a
celebrity and when people come up to you
like can I get a picture yeah yeah it
knocks out well done you're like oh [__]
all right yeah let's do it I get what
you're saying yeah it definitely takes
you away like I don't know if I can
trust this person as much to be an
actual friend yeah so Johnny Knoxville
sitting right in front of us in front of
us and in front of that is Trump and my
dude Johnny Knoxville I'm a jackass kid
like I [__] grew up see that was my
[__] like Travis Pastrana and the
jackass crew were like black Heroes bam
Stevo and I see him sitting there he's
enjoying himself and I tell Will I'm
like hey there he is he's [__] there
and was like I'll get you a photo with
him I don't please don't yeah no no no
no and the whole world because well if
you remember right I was like hey look
down in front of you stop and you know
he he loves Johnny oh yeah I know that's
like his favorite person because we
wanted to have him on the bus and stuff
too and I was
yo you're getting a photo with him and
he goes no no no don't do that I go I
swear to God if you don't like approach
and just be like yo I'm a fan at least
introduce yourself and I was like I'm
gonna go up and be like hey you know my
friend like he's a master fan oh dude I
was like oh my God I'm like bro you
gotta get it or you can do it some
people you didn't do it no he didn't
know or you can do it some people do and
still fight because I was like
afterwards oh damn it I'm going down the
night before like the main event Main
Event Johnny Knoxville
yeah you gotta go but yeah dude and we
were at the house that one night high as
hell dude we were like cooked like
figuring out life type of Cups marijuana
yeah okay and um would you say hey do
you think it was gay that I didn't no no
I I was I was I brought up the Johnny
thing and you're like yeah dude that was
so gay
and literally I was in I was in Cabo and
same thing with Vince Vaughn I love
Vince Vaughn and he's at this party I'm
at and I see him there's like 50 people
talking to him and I'm like I would love
to just [__] say hello to this guy
and I go to like the buses where they
like shutter everyone over to their
hotels and I'm waiting like hey boss is
give me 15 minutes I'm like I'm gonna go
[__] I'm gonna shake his hand I go
over there and I go to shake his hand
I'm like hey man just wanna let you know
been a fan of you my whole life love
what you do blah blah just want to shake
your hand say hello try to keep it super
cool right yeah he hits me with the hey
I appreciate that thank you very much as
our hands are
no law like going from touching and as
they separate an inch two guys calendar
size guys [__] shoulder to shoulder
with their back to me and essentially
Usher him away they're like you've had
your time and that was like hey bud I
just felt I went back to my hotel room
and like kind of like yeah look at
myself in the mirror like you're a
[__] [__]
look at you
[__] you'll love this okay just lives
down my where I've known Vince a lot
pretty long time so so I'm I I'm I'm I
I'm looking at Vince why is that
uh I just we've been here for 10 minutes
and you've named dropped Joe Biden
billing their friends welcome to find
the kid every single person
by the way I love you in The Hangover I
love being the warrior too
it doesn't matter did you guys say Biden
I know his brother man
he had brain surgery he did do I know
but I don't like this so do I know Vince
I've known him through the years you
know yeah and uh and hung out with them
been to his house blah blah blah so I
know I mean like this right yeah
so I I uh no I actually know him pretty
well
the reason I'm saying this is what we
got it yeah no but listen the point is
I've spent I've known him for
don't tell the story okay okay
I'm in the car with my wife and my buddy
and so we take salsa lessons so I'm with
my wife and our salsa there's it's a
couple and they're digged together and I
convinces there's a I'm here there's a
car here and invinces in the car over
there right right where in our
neighborhood and we're at the stoplight
and my buddy goes holy [__] it's been
fun and I haven't talked to Vince and
you know I don't know why so I go I go
bye-bye go hey and he goes and I go
what's up and he's like thank you thank
you
no no I'm going I'm going how you doing
and he goes he goes appreciate it thank
you I'm going good to see you hey bro
I'm like how do you know because thank
you and he's like this he's like thank
you like the ending he didn't recognize
me after [__] seven years I'm like
hey [__] up I sent him a video he was on
a set one
I don't know how much time like legit
know him really well so so him looking
at me and I was like you're that famous
that you just it wasn't his fault when I
said on the video I go hey dude I am a
fan but uh it's Brian Cowan and he just
goes love you pal LOL maybe you just
forgot you know dude that is yeah
is there any athlete you guys look up to
like that like because you're in the
you've been in the NFL but
that you'd be like like Johnny Knoxville
like you'd be like Star Struck by
um because you kind of know what they're
into let me throw out something Tom
Brady I think Tom Brady's forever Tom
would be sick there is a level of like
relatability since we've all played the
same game but yeah
um Brady right I mean uh Peyton Manning
yeah yeah I mean Peyton yeah Peyton
Brady Rogers
those are guys that are like older than
you enough to where like you've seen the
spectacle of him as a young kid
and then like we practice against Tom
Brady when he was with the Patriots you
did and he went we were doing a Red Zone
period And this is when like usually
when you do practices like teams will
split up like you guys will go over here
and then they'll do our drills and then
offense and defensive over here blah
blah and at the end of the day both
teams get on one field because there's
multiple fields and we'll do like two
minute situations where we'll do like
Red Zone situations
Tom did a Red Zone situation he went
seven for seven and [__] diced up our
defense and you're kind of just watching
like bro that's [__] calm he's a good
friends with Tom we've had a lot of
stuff
sorry I would be sick to meet uh Keekley
who's Luke
Hall of Famer come on the white
linebacker I jump out of your seat a
little bit no I'm a fan and he's retired
now I know your production really is
spelling that name like that Weekly Luke
hey our boys bad at the internet which
is mind-blowing but when I was
when I was in my third year I met Ray
Lewis and I was [__] like that's what
I was gonna ask you about what was that
like it was insane because he murdered a
guy no not at all
the street cred it was his crew really
that name is horrible that there's no
way to figure out this name quickly yeah
completely it was the Lou part that was
why why is that yeah you retired early
is that he retired early though he was I
mean all pro
Savage he was he was like he was a dude
that like you played against him and he
would call it the play you're about to
run that's how hard and he retired right
early because early concussions
nine years I sit across I sat across and
on a plane good run nines yeah but
nothing sounds better than ten brother
Joe yeah I mean I sat across from him
who's that Joe Montana and I remember
looking at him going I was like wait he
looks like a he doesn't look like he
looks like a regular guy now I mean he's
he's you know I was just like one of the
greatest quarterbacks ever and I had a
my business partner and I flew to Denver
to meet him and the way we're introduced
they go uh Aaron meet the most hated man
on the internet Brandon meet the most
hated man in the NFL that's how we met
oh wow oh my God
good to see you brother is Aaron is
Aaron like a hated man in the NFL though
uh yeah he's just like uh he was like
anti for being that Maxine yeah yeah
and he likes when you're that good yeah
you can do whatever you want whatever
he's there he's the man the NFL the
players
I'm sure all the players love it every
person I met you said to love him I mean
one of us one of the best people and
he's like you know he does all the
Psychedelic stuff like that and he's
like you'd be blown away how many
players come up to me like hey man I got
this and he's like educating them about
psychedelics now like how mushrooms help
them play get through the season stuff
he's the man yeah Aaron Rodgers is
really like that when I uh I signed my
second contract we were doing a
preseason game against the Packers and
like I wasn't really playing he wasn't
playing I was playing and I was going
like running for halftime and I get a
smack on the ass and I hear right don't
spend all that money in one place and I
look up and it's Aaron he's like kind of
jogging it's like slow-mo like in my
life but
is it looking back smiling I'm like oh
[__] moment he touched my ass yeah
that's full of [__] dude see how much
money these players are getting these
days man nuts I mean it's just the
standard right but I look at the
contract I'm like holy [__] insane the
NBA ones are
not so but he but across the board it's
just where the market's at for
everything like you look like Pat
McAfee's contract and people hit up
Stephen A Smith they're like how do you
feel they signed Pac McAfee he was like
this is good he's like because my
contract's up in the year right that's
where he's at and that's the that's
where he's because
no it's just it's just inflation it's
just the times and like this Market
players get that kind of Pat McAfee
money he he is you get a lot of Pat are
are essentially ESPN now correct I I
would bet my last dollar he gets more
than Pat
he's in all those conversations with the
top and people love him like he's so
well respected yeah he's crashing it man
yeah it looks like he's trying to get
into politics a little bit yeah he does
his podcast to talk a little bit about
it yeah I'd rather enjoy do you guys
missed the game or are you so happy that
you're doing this because you guys are
crushing this both I think both you do
Miss always going to miss it I mean you
don't it's like right now it's not like
I I go out and see training camps happen
and I think like thank God I'm not out
in this heat right now playing right but
you do think that I think like thank God
I'm not out there like I wouldn't want
to be [__] you know living in a
bubble and just going after [__] you
know that mountain for the season again
yeah but you definitely look back you
look back finally on all that [__]
because it was like when you're in it it
was the best yeah but when you know how
it is like you're just you're just like
chasing something with a like-minded
individuals you're in a Melting Pot the
locker room is the [__] that's what I
miss I miss the boys yeah
when I first got in comedy we had that
and it was like it filled this huge gap
and it was like oh this here it is I
found my pack my wealth mask yeah and
then pandemic hits and everyone goes
their separate ways yeah so in La the
comedy scene's done as far as like for
the comedy Rat Pack like it's just not
the hanging not there anymore it sucks
but that that used to fill the void now
that that's gone
stuff so what's keeping you here great
Point why don't you go to Austin why
don't you go to these places that
everyone's kind of we're talking about
things like that but you know we still
have some stuff going on here and and uh
not really but yeah but no I think but
but my thing is with Austin is when
everybody's doing that I don't want to
do that does that make sense like if I
move to Texas I'm going to like Fort
Worth right where where I can yell at
people stepping on my lawn like I want
Texas Texas Austin's more liberal than
here like I'm not gonna move somewhere
you can find if on the outside of your
circles yeah I mean I went to two gas
stations yesterday I played with
nicotine you want flavored nicotine yeah
but what are you doing Texas is is Sun
hot it's too hot I don't mind that it's
Bible hot I don't mind that biblical
dude you just got you got locusts you
got it's a 105 degrees there's 105 here
yesterday about well I guess I lived
closer to the beach yeah that oh slight
Flex I mean you're not on the beach
sprints on the sand do you guys have a
minute
um you're more in Redondo but we'll call
it Manhattan hey bro
you're more inner bro I hate when people
get detailed with my [__] stories
because I'm exposed to someone
back to uh Missing not did you know that
you know their associated with bar stool
Barstool this is one of the greatest
business stories of all time Dave
portnolay he's sold right he sold the
company got the company back for a
dollar that's been one of the greatest
what business week just last week how
[Music]
um
go ahead and jump into it they weren't
acquiring as much market share in the
gambling space that they had wanted to
so they had to make a pivot to make a
pivot they wanted to get in bed with
ESPN to get in bed with ESPN they had
the uh disassociate with Barstool so
when you got a call barcel up barcel's
got you know whether it's a leverage
game or not it's like hey we got to get
rid of this we'll sell it back to you
and it was basically for a non-compete
and some upside if you were to sell
again but this is
but this is what's great all the boys I
don't know if Taylor does but most of
boys on Barstool including Dave all have
stock they have equity in pen gambling
oh so and then pens can go through the
roof like right now people like oh it
said pens you know they're they're done
look at the stocks eat it wait till
fancy football starts and everyone has
to start betting with pen that Stock's
gonna go through the phone ESPN bet
which is you get the week at the root
for it correct you want it to do well
you want like McAfee you want all of
them to get very well the mistake Penn
made is then listen I'm part of that
crew too where Barstool some wow wild
boys what we do is we're wild boys Joe
Rogan the whole crew to Stefano Tim
Dillon Bert Kreischer wild boys when he
put us in corporate world it's going to
ruffle some feathers especially with a
lot of regulations yeah so and they're
like wait they said what it's like
that's how we built our fan base yeah oh
he can't say this well that doesn't work
dude right so then Penn just
miscalculated that a little bit now that
we go to ESPN with woke Disney and you
know bat out of Mickey Mouse which is
fine yeah and they'll make their money
and that's where all that's what they
should be doing yeah they try to
Barstool and God bless them for even
trying because most companies are too
scared to right so God bless them but
like even going back because obviously
hindsight's 2020 it's like yeah okay
they look at it now they didn't get
enough market share but at that time
when they acquired Barstool for 500
million dollars right DraftKings FanDuel
everybody else the way that they spent
their advertising dollars is just
licensing and paying Talent individual
Talent so like us Leah like Callan we'll
give you a 100 million dollar bag
Brandon will give you 100 million dollar
bag and so you're like licensing deals
whereas pin had acquired a company is
like we're gonna have Barstow push all
of our stuff we don't have to pay
advertising dollars for anybody else but
now you look back fan doing DraftKings
have a much bigger market share than
Penn does so now Penn had to sell it
back and now they're paying a two
billion dollar licensing deal for 10
years with ESPN big boy deals
Incredible App such a credible like
company ESPN I mean ESPN now but you
know that and it's kind of we were
talking about this yesterday how it's
kind of like there's a race going on in
the in the gambling world of who's going
to be Numero Uno and I think FanDuel and
DraftKings they they own one and two and
it's like three DraftKings but yeah
we'll see I want to say FanDuel might be
number one right now is FanDuel up there
it seems like it seems like the biggest
player in the whole sports betting space
is like the tech well I'm a DraftKings
guy promo code fighter okay gambling is
a true American Pastime I mean I'm
always amazed at how many people gamble
there's so much it is wild uh online's
the big deal like with fantasy football
but it's tough because it's not legal
and in California it's not legal in some
states yeah so it's Obama yeah it sucks
about the nicotine in California but
that is rough too the next thing you
keep bringing it up but that's [__]
nice
people don't realize like that [__]
meal like had a big deal and I have a
new deal but I did have this big deal
with this nicotine company and I was
like your poster boy and then you know
California is my main market and then
when they stop doing the flavored
version like dude it doesn't make sense
for us anymore I'm like new some you
piece of [__] oh he he that became a law
yeah you can't have flavored nicotine I
can't flavor nicotine you know what that
is dude and it makes it doesn't make
sense what they're taught because the
Vapes uh the flavored Vapes so across
the board like no flavor they don't want
kids doing it because they have like
Skittles and like the reason why they're
doing it makes sense he puts them in his
at the same time yeah how many do you do
a lot of things what do you do because I
do three milligrams I do two at a time
though because I'm more of a flavor guy
over the afternoon six milligrams 24
times you see the cheeks he can [__]
fit a lot in there yeah you know but
that's a lot of nicotine huh that's a
lot of nicotine that's he's a nicotine
guy I'm not but
you don't either [__] hey bro really
so true yeah on the road sometimes I
sneak a little three I have but I'm
saying overall I'm not no no you're not
an acting guy it doesn't it doesn't
control but you're a caffeine guy what
are you what is it I'll do caffeine yeah
yeah me too big caffeine guy I like your
coffee like eight o'clock and I'll still
go to bed at 9 30. yeah which is wild to
me I can't believe you can do that same
I cannot I love coffee how about how
about food what's your what's your booze
of choice Twisted Tea yeah Twisted Tea
is definitely that's a sponsor dude
whether you're grilling out or watching
the big game what you want to [__]
drink dude it's a non-confidence
does it go with ice oh my God does it
what the [__] man
sure a nice mason jar filled with
Twisted Tea with rocks in it and the
sweat going outside of the Mason jar oh
nice sunlight today dude yeah
you're here dude you're not at your
beach house you're out here in the heat
right now there's nothing to do you run
to a gas station what do you see you see
it's wizard to you crack that thing it's
perfectly okay keep your hand cold and
the more you sip it not only is it
refreshing but you start to get that
warm fuzzy feeling like maybe I can do
anything promise oh man dude it's
probably brewed in China what probably
brooding child it's American names
Boston what in the world's going on here
why am I twisted tealess do you guys
still mess with the Whistle Pig you
still have your whiskey yes oh you still
have our whiskey oh yeah that's good too
but it's got a bunch of big ears
it might be the only whiskey that
changes with the seasons dude when
you're cold outside
man I need to warm up a little bit oh
yeah a little bit a little glass of
that's uh
busting select no Whistle Pigs legit
you don't know how smooth it is yeah
picture yourself taking a sip you smell
a little bit of caramel yeah yeah you
smell a little bit of black pepper yeah
it hits right when it hits your lips you
might feel a little fright thinking like
okay this could be a little dangerous
going down as it goes down the throat
picture yourself sitting in a backyard
again Autumn evening yeah swaying on a
hammock the bird is going back to the
next that is how smoothly it goes it is
nice you brought it and then when it
sits on your stomach nice and warm wow I
feel like I'm home does it feel like a
home when it hits much you're ready to
turn up the game can I just talk about
something do you guys have anything in
mind that I can take in the morning
because to me I like coffee but it's so
expensive and I love New Tropics dude I
love benefits of new tropics and I just
if you guys have something it's so crazy
sense of flow
energized and I want to be in Flow State
24 7. I want to be like Superman and the
[__] wind is going you want your cup
of my hair because I'm [__] going no
turbulence well if you want that if you
want to feel like you're on a crotch
rocket without you're getting in the
road and there's no resistance yeah I'd
say there's a there's there's a tincture
I call Magic Mike can I put it over ice
you can put it over anything you want
can you did you say I scan you what's it
called it's called Magic mine and it's
magic but it comes in a small bottle
like this I mean only if you're into
antioxidants up the Wazoo and you're
into it's like a Five Hour Energy Shot
but it's super it's good Chris Angel of
nootropic but it's magic something that
beneficial something that amazing
there's no way it's got to be super
expensive
try about three dollars a shot bro Maybe
hey bro come on take it easy no it's
cheaper than coffee though right yeah
yeah
I can only imagine what it's here
the best shot of energy and the
possibility come on I'll tell you
something else you're built like and
I've never said this before your bill
like Authority
oh well I like hold on let me screech
and gold
you put that [__] back in back in first
gear let's keep writing I like that yeah
my authority no I like it okay I enjoyed
it I feel like Authority
fellas when when did you realize you're
over the hump like after you start
booking big guests but at what point was
it when when Taylor retired because you
guys went from doing well Taylor's still
playing brother I'm an active NFL are
you still an actor I'd appreciate if you
did your [__] homework though hey I
didn't like how you said you and will
were friends for so long
when you're on Rogan and you said how
funny will was a bunch of times because
you guys were real strong about
[Applause]
dude you brought up a good point yeah
because lewin's fun have been called Lou
in my whole life state championship
state championship game sophomore year
when 15-0 got myself a ring I got called
to Luna as I was running out because I
was starting as a sophomore but
I'm pretty sure somebody in this room
I'm not going to say name said something
like busting with the Bros that's his
little this is like I always it's my
that's your thing it's something I don't
it has to be a mentor no what happened
you know what I think it's more football
than USC you think so yeah those are
buffaloes yep and you're headed
downstairs
welcome to your future oh no no well as
I was no no my personal space taken away
from Calvin as I was trying to [__] he
wanted to have a conversation with me
about CT I was sitting on his [__]
line yeah I was I said don't worry I'm
holding that it's clean let me clean but
even though you guys are active uh NFL
football players don't laugh when you
say I'm not bro you do it again you're
just lighting the ass for a tackle okay
let me try again
I'm not gonna laugh even though you guys
are over you're pursuing over the hump
with pie tied in that yeah
the humps there you guys are still
outstanding but with the with the Pod
you guys are doing your thing doing your
thing and at some point just went
yeah what do you think it was
you're just more focus on it to you
coming on the first time busting the
boys I feel like that hurt you
what do you think it was though I think
just more football players like getting
familiar with you guys or did the NFL
kind of loosen up the reins there a
little bit she's got some like Travis
Kelsey on I think with podcasts like the
advice we got in the beginning was be
consistent and with just a level of
consistency and then getting guys like
you know I'll give you a compliment I'll
give you both a compliment consistently
for sure you have that thing that that
very few people have when it comes
podcasts don't work with most people and
some people like you guys chemistry and
also just your personalities it just
works I knew that the the day I did your
podcast some people just are able to do
it you guys listen you add some it's a
dance there's a chemistry and especially
with your knowledge but I think this is
the future of sports as far as
broadcasting goes like what Pat McAfee's
doing I'm not taking anything away from
Pat anything from you guys in the locker
rooms I've been in there's a lot guys
like that man there's a lot of guys can
[__] talk they're funny they're smart
I know the whole Meathead jock thing is
there I'm telling I've been some locker
rooms whether it's UFC NFL is there for
two weeks but in college where there's
some dudes
a cup of coffee a cup of coffee they're
all set on slow white guys but um
there's some dudes in those locker rooms
where I'm like man put a mic in front of
them they're gonna Crush oh yeah there's
those guys they just got to be pushed in
that direction I think when players see
you guys doing it they're seeing what
Pat's doing and the real money coming in
they're like oh this is Elaine I can go
down it's like yeah dude you see I think
there's a lot more guys
that was chin we get that clip yeah
guy who created to Willie dude this is
this is his baby because when we first
when will first came on the team people
were like hey Will confident Taylor want
to be best friends it was literally
being said in the on the bird and will
and I met we it was like right away good
buddies and but we bonded over the
fighter and the Kid Joe Rogan
congratulations with and all that and
then at the end of the season will and I
are the Chinese a shady Chinese
restaurant and he's like I want to do a
podcast let's do a podcast it was all
will and I was like all right I'll do it
and then I left to go to California
surprise you welcome
like me though smart that's why me and
will [__] with each other what what I'm
just saying as far as like
I said catch all that no no
you want to give yourself
you go
yeah but no because it's because similar
when we first started podcast Prime was
gone all the time and it was my baby
it's all it was like no man we're gonna
make movies work movie start yeah TV Hey
Brother using the Joker Kingdom
he's in King like uh was it uh in
Kingdom the kingdom it was just called
the TV series Kingdom I gotta I gotta
turn that on that's my bad you know what
as we're dishing out compliments you
were [__] fantastic on our show thank
you buddy the wolf at the door oh yeah
is what the [__] is that quote I want to
say it all the time luxury is the wolf
at the door luxury is the wolf and that
that uh that link too that little story
that was nice the catastrophe of success
yeah well smoke well spoken individual
for sure
smart guy been around for quite some
time has some stories he also knows
everybody knows everyone long long story
person you know most famous person I'll
answer that Joe Rogan yeah that's right
that's fair that's besides Joe
um Biden
which one I mean you know name a
billionaire I know a lot of people you
know where they got really famous like
Bradley Cooper guys like that and then
they get super famous and you lose touch
they're too busy for you bubbly yeah
yeah just don't you get older and you
just don't Kevin Hart he knows Kevin
Hart I know Kevin Hart okay no well
could you call him right now
if I saw Kevin but I don't you know if I
maybe I used to text with him a lot but
you know he changed his number he got
he's so famous people like that are like
I don't know I I wouldn't reach out but
also he's probably like yeah what yeah
what do you need to talk to you yeah I
mean I've done two movies with him so I
spent a lot of time on set with him yeah
probably gave him a lot of ideas well we
had he's he's Johnny legs John and
Johnny let go we're at the movie
festival it took him a while to
recognize you but that's whatever Jamie
Foxx at a at a party
came up to me and said he goes he goes
uh you don't say hi I've been waiting
for you the one the one comic in the
room and I don't get anything from you
and he's giving me like and this is when
I was dating my wife and she was like
she was watching this and he's making a
fuss and she's like he starts talking to
me about how he did a set in DC that is
a tough well listen you're fine with it
but I'm saying he gave you
again Kudos she danced because she was
like you know that black guy don't dance
with him yes she did she did he he was
Jamie Foxx
she had braids she had her sneakers on
and my girl Ken [__] dance and she
and your wife had braids and sneakers on
yeah and she was at we were at a
Hollywood party and she was dancing she
went there for one reason Dad she was
dancing and I was like wow and yeah and
she dated some professional black
athletes in the past and so you got a
hog is what you're saying well I do he
does has she seen bigger yeah listen we
don't know if that's the case well hey
I'll say his name there's the captain of
the Dallas Cowboys going to Vickers one
of my best friends in college yeah his
dick was so big as a mic and talk into
it after this dance what do you think
and move it outside into it yeah so he
had the ability when he was younger
that'll change though he still has it
that'll change your life I'm sure these
guys that she dated had tiny dicks um
tiny pieces give you a better
personality you have like fat chicks
with their uh personalities yeah yeah
yeah
goes well we get to hide ours though
lizos have you heard all this stuff
about her coming out yeah she's a big
girl sucks apparently she's fat shaming
her crew I don't want to get too much
into it Delia said it best he goes if
somebody says you're fat if Liza calls
you fat you go oh yeah you are too
he's like that's the comeback he is so
funny the videos of YouTube
going back and forth classic [__]
well I'll sit there in bed double chined
up [__] phone on my chest watching
have you guys had because you're in uh
Nashville still have you guys had deal
on recently since last time no Theo
doesn't mess with the boys it's weird he
does but he does he does but he does
he's Out Of Reach he's almost too big
he's in reach but he's out here he's
almost too big now but every time he
sees us he's like hey me and Caleb Kayla
Presley from Sunday conversations who's
I feel anybody has ever seen that it's
incredible he's brilliant he's like
we're gonna come out at the same time
and that's usually where it ends with an
I love you as he walks away but hey you
just never want to you never feel like
you're like I don't like pushing too
much is there more of a brilliant mind
in this world than Theo as far as comedy
as far as like yeah wit thinking it's
insane it is how his brains we were
walking up all that childhood trauma he
was backing up and we're like hell why
are you backing up is not the man the
ground's moving just like that and he
told will like you're not in football
you're in I'll say bro we're in the same
industry he goes you're in uh Dental
advertising yeah he's just a size he
goes you got your teeth from uh Taylor's
knee surgery
he's kneecaps
so he's so you know what there's nobody
else like him he's so unique so yeah and
I didn't realize Caleb uh Presley he
played quarterback in college at North
Carolina yeah yeah I just found him he
played with who's the who's the country
singer uh Chase Rice oh oh I love cheese
yeah
together
Luke Combs didn't play ball
how big how tall is Luke same high
school oh but they didn't play ball I
saw a video of Luke Combs chugging a
chug in a beer and I'd like a I'd like a
stab at him five nine who is that Luke
Combs he's one of the biggest customers
in the world okay he's mad
he shotgun to beer
um he does it on stage all the time he
did it on Rogan and he's quick but
you're you're pretty quick Hey Kevin did
you give me the invite for the uh the
bear games with these guys yeah
mine must got lost in the mail that's on
us I don't know I think I might have
texted you nope that's on us an invite
foreign
I can't say to my wife listen take care
of the kids I gotta go to the Beer
Olympics you went to Columbia last week
went to Columbia I did go to play grab
us I did but that was a that was a paid
game you guys very much I told you too
because I when I saw that I was like
[__] I forgot the boys Beer Olympics
look at that
him
or her that's that's hardy hardy and his
wife and his wife she is a [__] rock
star dude let's go baby we're here we're
like winners
Georgetown the force Buckner
absolutely throttle probably the best
tied in the game I think look at you
guys see him pull him up I didn't even
recognize you guys there's George Kittle
he said get to the job I need to show
him my four seconds all right kettles
this kettle's a specimen yeah brother
and the nicest human being of all time
you can block his ass off that's why I
have him over Kelsey yeah dude
he's a dog yeah he can do both I mean
like Kelsey's probably better at
receiving yeah
George Kittle oh we were having this
conversation who would you rather have
who'd rather have on your team memes
uh George because he's a dog he's a
[__] dog
it's like like if Kelsey's a 10 he's a
nine and a half yeah but then that block
that dog in him Kelsey got that [__]
wiggle man that's what I love you got
that wiggle that you just can't oh I
can't teach it I root for that dude
every okay can we have some silence are
we ready to go ready to go watch Taylor
here
[Music]
are you chugging Twisted Tea yeah oh boy
oh Jesus oh three beers bro what that
throat do Daddy I went to prison these
are all pro football players what's that
these you guys are all uh you're tired
bro I would never recognize you uh those
two Corey Levin Jordan ruse
V Buckner
dude in the Chug on chubby I think like
nine seconds his movie premiere was like
a month or two before Beer Olympics and
we we were up we were invited which was
great but there was like a clip before
playing all the stuff yeah we've
numbered forever he's just he's the best
and uh there was a clip of him doing
flip cup and I leaned over to Willie
this is game over brother he's not gonna
stand a chance no and they did a decent
in flip cup but I think they who was
Bert's partner Shane
and Shane can put it down jelly can chug
he can drink the moment got too big for
him when he did his chug he ended up
spilling all over himself but he
panicked he can chug now he can [__]
move and he can [__] talk dog
who's your guys's favorite comedian
right now like who's just like crushing
it
favorite but I would say
I'm starving do you have any like
healthy like tasty snacks you want some
chocolate covered macadamia nuts dude
I'm not a millionaire dude House of
macadamia works with all these farmers
in South Africa okay rural communities
okay and that's why they're able to get
macadamia nuts at a price you can afford
yeah but I don't like just regular nuts
they have I don't know it's covered in
like Raspberry Vanilla sure you want
white chocolate you want you want
regular chocolate this is crazy
you want spicy we got spicy dude what
what about if I like bars
dude we'll I'll get you some macadamia
nut bars so 45 macadamia nut bars I got
there I need a variety pack on the house
though I got that for you too now here's
the thing you like coffee
yeah I'm a coffee company you ever have
coffee with Macadamia milk dude I see
what you're doing right now and I you
know I can't afford that stuff dude it's
too expensive okay you're saying
macadamia nut milk I'm talking about
house in Macadamia Jeff Bezos they
didn't stop just at their extra virgin
macadamia nut oil okay they didn't stop
it they're nuts and all the different
kinds of macadamia nuts with all their
different Coatings you can get but they
said you know what people need macadamia
nuts in their coffee step the game up
there yeah that's right so when you do
taste it be ready to freak the flip out
but can I get 20 off and a free pack of
the Macadamia snack bars let me check
hold on let me see let me text with them
oh they just said yes what do I have to
do though go to House of macadamias.com
tfak I get 20 off my entire order yeah
with the code tfak plus I get the
variety free box of 45 Macadamia snack
bars that's right insane insane I don't
know I like right now who's the best
best
I mean it's just it's all kind of it's
all subjective yeah but I mean you
watching you're like okay this is my I
don't watch too much because I don't
want to do this Bill Burr when we were
watching Bill Burr the Laugh Factory a
while ago
[Music]
um
I even called him yeah I mean Bill
Bill's the go Bill's the goat David tell
but I think as far as like that young
like the that that class right there
obviously Shane Gillis is a beast
um Mark Norman's a Monster yeah but
that's a big Jake I think I like those
guys they're great but they're too young
I mean I think the guys that are that
are kind of astonishing the people that
I've seen when's last time you saw Shane
Gillis uh it's been a while Savage
I think he's got something coming up
dude it's insane
stop live right I just haven't see just
chain I'm saying the last time I saw
somebody and was like kind of Blown Away
was Bill Burr I was like that was a hot
second girl doing it forever dude Bill's
like unbelievable Shane's like 12 years
ago
Shane's been doing it forever he's great
no Shane's like 12 years in not that
he's not no but apparently the stuff
he's doing now Rogan was telling me his
last specialist monster he's [__]
inside you know who I love with Mirage
yeah and literally will and I like it
between pause which is looking to be
like bro hang on hang on hang on we
can't let Shane hear this concert yeah
you know but you know who else is crazy
enough you know you know what else
there's a monster you guys just had on
he one of the funniest people in the
world is uh Chris DiStefano dog he is
yeah bro his wit was catching me off
guard because I was you were ready for
it right I wasn't ready
is much more calm calculated and before
we had to go on like hey he's a little
hard to open up in a podcast blah blah
blah he was great the girls are
different than DeStefano he's different
the Stefano came in and was just he was
you better be ready
you better be ready to go be able to
handle himself like it was and he's
always on yeah just like you like you
might be a little prickly sometimes
Chris always up yeah and it's fun too
he's just got like a positive energy and
it's just at 100 he was a D3 athlete
doesn't count where I come from but
still got where I come from
yeah
basketball okay who basketball is hard
to be just definitely yeah white guy
that basketball stripper handsome though
DeStefano tough to be that handsome yeah
your body's all right his face though
it's good face is good he wears those
Dahmer glasses yeah
that kid's got a piece on him you think
so I know so he has wide hips seems like
a lunch who's this Stephano he's got an
astonishing piece yes yeah he's got a
he's gotta you better you what's your
takeout what's your take on Matt Rife I
love Madison
but I mean he's not old enough for you
to know him forever well you know Matt
I've known since he was probably 18 19.
16. he was at the Laugh Factory
hey Will he's one of the most selling
comedians he sold out his entire tour
for two years he's doing Arena he's
always working he's the fastest to blow
up like that in this day and age because
off Tick Tock off his crowd work
he works hard yeah but he didn't let the
white guy talk but whatever he
he's always worked hard he's always been
humble he's always been a great kid like
for me anyway I met him because we met
him you'd come around the Laugh Factory
or whatever all the time and we're in
the parking lot and uh Kate Beck sale
walks up my holy [__] like she's a
unicorn man who's with her he was he was
like 18. yep and by the way how about
this how about this about this rage all
line on the couch I asked him about Kate
pack and sale and this is when he and he
said to me and he was probably 21 or
something and I wanted to know some
questions he goes I can't I can't really
talk about her I wanna I gotta protect
her privacy that's what this kid said at
22. I mean does it look like you know
mom and son there yeah it does yeah but
he pulled it off dude shout out to him
but he's crushing it right now he's he's
doing a world tour right now she's in
Van Helsing he's making yes crazy yeah
private I got you dude I'm with you now
wasn't she also in Underworld
yeah I don't like that movie though
she's impossibly beautiful what about
Fast and the Furious you like Fast and
the Furious I hate that [__] I really
like action movies whoa come on man name
a good action movie that's a blanket
statement that's going to catch you in a
ball situation well well like I like
like old school like uh Bloodsport Rambo
action Commando John Wick hate it what
hate it me too this guy's on a revenge
tour because they killed his dog Jason
please Jason Bourne hate it hate it okay
the dog that his wife his dead wife got
for him not buying beating a heart that
still like gives him hope nope not
buying it I'm out damn Transformers [__]
you let's talk about uh The Equalizer
like Denzel Washington yeah suck my dick
he's 90. why are you a haters I am
second I Am Legend uh yeah nice that
one's pretty good now we're getting into
things hold on Daddy Dark Knight hold on
dog yes those are those hold on are
those action [__] yes no what do you
clarify him as but they're character
pieces yeah there's more I need a story
great movie American Gladiator yes good
movie of course but there's a story
it's a great movie but but with uh with
uh Keanu Reeves like in that [__] I
don't I don't like it it's not for me
that's okay but that's a hater
give me a more recent action movie like
for instance I don't like fast and
furiouses
you know what I checked out when they
were uh going to space yeah you know
it's a fun old movie Avengers to run
down you ever see the rundown
yeah Knoxville hell yeah that's a really
good Full Metal Jacket great movie
that's a great rock with Sean Connor
those are all old boyfriend the original
it's the greatest movie if the Iron
Giant is categorized as an action movie
then you're [__] bro this has good
Fellas as an action movie so this list
is full of [__] no no it's the top the
top row only here's what I'll get with
Troy how about General I did not like I
thought the Matrix I did not like the
Matrix [__] check please The Matrix
is revolutionary though what's the hey
with the action movies Tombstone
phenomenal great movie not an action
that's a West yes it is it's a it's a
western with some action if somebody
dies it's action
Warriors great movie Warriors crashing
tiger great movie unforgiving one of the
best of all time Black Hawk Down hey
guys these are like the Blackhawks of
all time Scarface yeah they're all good
movies he's all won like a lot of awards
I'm talking I'm talking like Fast and
Furious Transformers
the Mage you should see where you caught
yourself in a position of saying look at
the genres of action movies you know
what the promise is our level of
communication because my my definition
of action is different than yours
that's you not communicating your
definition of action well I'm over here
you say action what am I supposed to say
well I wonder what Shaw's definition of
that is that's exactly introduction and
that's exactly
your genres hey you know what the
promise you know what the problem it's
not conception I know sure you know what
the promise is not with me and you it's
with chin because he Googled action
movies
all of the James Bond movies are good
Mad Max is a great movie all of that
yeah you Mission Impossible fan I am
check please why dude he doesn't do
another check yeah Mission Impossible
rips obviously it doesn't like period I
love rainbow movies you know why I love
it you know I loved it because it's a
Maverick dude
I needed that for us I need you to say
that for us you know what you got me
yeah yeah that's the one you got man
that's a good Predator Tom Cruise is a
phenomenal actor oh he's great he's
phenomenal dude he's phenomenal get a
reading a Jurassic anyway doesn't matter
I like the new ones we spent I spend
some time with it but I love it in
Nostalgia you guys have kids have you
seen the new Teenage Mutant Ninja
Turtles not yet bro might be better than
spider-verse better than the original
Ninja Turtles that we grew up on I'm
telling you dude it's [__] well done
you don't you either have four parents
girl girl comes in December but I have
two boys now girl comes December hell
yeah that three piece dude
congratulations you want more yes you
have to you don't have any only kids
suck can't give it just one I've been
dropping semen Team Six in recently
we'll see what happens but have you been
have you have you checked it out though
because all the football you
testosterone the swimmers might not be
you might not have a full Squad there's
what I'm saying I've been uh working
with somebody yeah you have to there you
go look at them somebody called tell me
that's natural yeah look at Will Compton
dude Will finds his way through he's not
built like a classic linebacker Ray
Lewis would shove him around the locker
room but let me tell you he was a Prof
professional and an active professional
linebacker in the NFL going on how many
years now going on 10.2 right now that's
actually
It's actually an insane that's an insane
achievement to be to be as he's not he's
go ahead he's a very honest look at him
he's very unassuming and to be that good
for that long is a big fight see that
body right there that's a [__] solid
pound are you talking about the solids
but he's competing against genetic
Freaks and he's
he's a very athletic guy will offline is
a phenomenal linebacker you put him on
the line but he's smart he's smart
remember that practice but wait what is
it about how it was a jog through and he
wanted to [__] block me a [__]
[__]
now now Taylor you're the [__] you had
some good job taylor
super freak speed size Wills Will's
working with like
his brain
yeah yeah but I mean thank you yeah is
the plan to go to say that part what did
you want my pride and joy right there
four or five four five six it's fast
though that's fast you have csb yes no
he's a freak man you can't yeah no he's
tough guy yeah well that's what I'm
saying
for 10 years that's so that's so crazy
to me
it's kind of crazy
four five six
okay what's going on he's not buying it
you're doing what shot that's the way
I'm not gonna do yeah you're right don't
do that do that don't do that wait you
can question it I don't want your wing
call the option put him on speakerphone
I'm diving two right now he did that at
a pro day and a pro day
I've heard numbers can get a little
different I didn't run into pro day so I
don't know would you would you run in
such a dick what'd you run I run a four
eight five four eight five yeah at his
size is the combines three times when
you got the combine you look down at the
pro day because the pro day you have you
have all the scouts there and and a lot
of them do it by hand you know what uh
I'll be first to admit my ego's gone in
the way in this conversation already
I I can I can totally see you later
this whole village
Saucy yeah that's a saucy vertical 32
yeah that's very respectful yeah that's
[__] beat my numbers I was a four six
guy but I'll tell you this on the
vertical my vertical is never 32. it's
like when they measure you you're like
your shoulder down you gotta cheat yeah
now are you boys playing with the
football season coming up are you guys
planning to because you were going to
the are you gonna do like live shows at
the games
are you going to do some of that like
once you go into camps like some of the
trainings our College tailgate tour yes
we'll go on weekends to college tailgate
tours and anybody who wants our services
on the uh NFL level will usually have to
wait till December or January that makes
sense you boys are packed now are we
planning to go to we plan to go to
University of Colorado see he's popping
I want to go week two Nebraska we're
gonna beat them
you guys are not going don't don't you
know what my problem is with CU is the
expectations like all my boys still
there right yeah we won one game last
year and the the stuff out they're like
dude we're going Championship like hey
[__] if we just win five I'll be stoned
the overhead is three and a half yeah
three and a half years I'll bet on that
all day I think I would think I will
they're taught their first five games
are tough thunder right because I think
they're going over I'm going I think
Dion's gonna brainwash I think those
[__] their talent levels here
say it again say that say the word
you're gonna say again what brainwashed
yeah yeah that's what you need to do in
college I think Dion I think Dion can
Inspire and influence any groupies
especially especially but look at the
talent they have there was a video that
came out of dudes fighting and uh
fighting on the field and he's like no
he said I saw two of y'all walking away
while somebody was fighting one fight we
all fight dog dog
tell it all telling his team a lot of
coaches bringing up hey we're fighting
we're running see again I think they're
going to be good but the the
expectation's Bolder I'm gonna take some
heat for this but they're like we're
going champ we're top five I'm like bro
yeah temper expectations we won one game
but the problem is the fan base is
expecting like this insane season their
first five games are tough if they win
two they're gonna be as soon as they
lose a game Nebraska people that's not
happening as soon as they lose a game
people will be furious who's the head
coach in Nebraska now coach rule coach
rule yeah and I really like coach wool
if you look at coach Will's track record
yeah where he was at where'd he come
from
NFL but before that he was at um Baylor
temple temple that's what I was thinking
of Temple and you look at this track
record it's like it takes like two or
three years and then they end up getting
close to that double digits if not
double digit wins yeah so this this is
the best couple years away but they're
in good hands yeah but they still have
hands was there ever a player that you
guys dreaded being opposite so was there
a running back
really just a nightmare just any running
back anytime I'm in coverage on the
running backs in a running back motions
out to empty and for whatever reason we
want to stay in main coverage and I need
to run out there every time why is that
just because it's just gonna not my game
we're gonna be in the Box let me see the
field a little bit right let me
anticipate man coverage against [__]
like Melvin Gordon or something because
the speed you gotta cover him he's going
out for a power yeah I mean yeah because
he's in charge of that because when the
the run back comes out yeah and they're
in man coverage that's his guy you got
to follow you so once you get outside
the box and you're covering you feel a
lot he's out his comfort zone you're
more yeah you're out of your comfort
zone yeah you have to play a lot more
you have to be fluid with your hips and
everything else not saying my hips
weren't ever fluid but they are tighter
compared to the Ray Lewis's of the world
yes you know what I'm saying yeah the
Fred Warner's who are out there that can
do it all let's do it all it's not
necessarily always pressures on you now
you could just she's like oh yeah when
you know you're in a trips far gun
situation and the quarterback looks at
the running back and they get an option
route you're a liability and you know
the ball's probably going to him
especially if he's open yes that's why
you tap your D end on the ass hey Butch
hit him before hit him hit him out of
the back what about your sack yeah hit
this [__] to help me out and as
an offensive lineman you hear Butch
you're like thank God because now I
don't have to block this guy yeah
because he now has to chip the chip the
running back to help will out so he's
not going after the quarterback which
helps me out oh did you fellas see the
you who who did you hate being uh
opposite my first couple of years
um
who's a DN for the Raiders troll sucks
my rookie here he he [__] dude that
dude had an ass you could put a [__]
well another have you ever seen him
another guy with a yeah well I know
about it he looks like a velocity about
him but with big arms so so I'm doing a
movie this is such a weird story I'm
doing a [__] you know him I'm gonna
freak out here I'm doing a movie
we had a photographer who was taking
pictures he's played we're in Baltimore
and it was called I do and I don't and
we had this photo shoot and this is we
were with women and Jane Lynch people
and the photographer
in front of all of us because he goes
I'm just traumatized and I said what he
goes you know who Terrell Suggs is and I
did I don't know a lot of football
players and he goes uh and he said he
goes he changed in front of me
he's like it's so traumatically large
that I just have to tell something about
it and I go what's that he goes you know
the spray cave paint cans but the long
ones that's what I said yeah and I never
every time I think about him I think
about that yeah that must have been so
anyway he put that dick on me a couple
of times my rookie here that's a weird
story I enjoyed it it always gets back
to the day
but that's that's that was he was such a
freak yeah we played them on my rookie
year at Baltimore and they were
announcing the defense and they said
Terrell Suggs the place went crazy and
he was wearing a gladiator mask oh no I
go oh [__] why was that just because he
was so much to handle he was he was he's
a Hall of Famer he's so awesome and the
Ravens then their defenses with Ray
Lewis Terrell Suggs Ed Reed Ed Reed yes
and they just had the purple the black
the their whole stadium used to beat
people up man God like they do their
individual uh you're in a fight every
play yeah oh yeah yeah and but like he
was at that point where he was trying to
get older where he would take plays off
like he would go slower in plays you
could tell he wasn't really interested
but like you getting a third and eight
situation or more it's like holy [__] he
turns it off for dear life yeah because
he wants those sacks and then there was
Elvis uh doomerville
yes Louisville he was a smaller
oh so that's absolutely that's a bit
that's the most important that's why you
got paid the big bucks you're protecting
the blind's a nice little girl yeah okay
like the real Blind Side not this big
thing yeah well that's tough too to hear
about well Michael Oher was on my team
my rookie year oh was he yeah yeah and
he was did he talk about it back then he
talked about a little bit like
a rookie with his name Gay biker he was
undrafted guy from Oklahoma he was all
American too I can't believe he was
undrafted but he came up his girlfriend
now wife her favorite movie is the blind
time so first they were there he walks
up walks up and takes a photo like this
without asking her what's your favorite
movie Blind Side yeah I'd say get out
family he takes he takes a photo a
selfie with uh or without asking him at
all that next day the history coach
Watterson is like I heard there's
rookies trying to take photos with vets
and he just made us run Dan just made us
run the whole time and we ran for like
you know 15-20 minutes but he was saying
like he hated the movie because they
make him look like an idiot he's like I
knew I know well it sounds like he's
also a snitch though a little bit right
what How's he snitch because he went and
told the strength coach that guy took my
picture
the guy took his what took his picture
oh yeah that's a good point I didn't put
that [__] all together that's that
football club on your own yeah that buns
me out yeah hey brother don't hey don't
you like to think that maybe somebody
else saw it yeah I was gonna say I hope
that yeah I don't think that happened
because Mike no no no yeah keep to
himself did you because did you hear
Dave Portnoy had the family on
dude that was somebody was and when you
listen to the family talk I was like oh
I'm with them on this because the dad
was like we love him we shouldn't do
this he actually texted like the family
group chat was okay if you don't pay me
this amount of money I'm gonna go public
and the dad was like public with what
we've done nothing to you go ahead bud
like we've we've done nothing to you and
then Dad was like Hey honestly like this
whole money thing he goes I'm not even
trying to flex but I sold my company for
300 million dollars a few years ago like
we don't need money from this guy it's
nothing that's not what's going on here
he's like it's not a money to take a
nice little dive on that yeah it's a
good it's hard to say anything about it
right now because all right you know I I
don't know either it's like he said she
said I've been around that SJ kid though
a couple times wow boy
yeah interesting yeah but he like
I mean it might have been Michael's
money if that's what he's saying but
like he you know he had it he was like
in his young early 20s had a watch like
the one you're wearing
they had it the dad said that like each
family member including Michael or got
like 15 or 16 000 each it's like well
why did the little kid get it why'd the
little white boy get it yeah that makes
sense he did nothing he did nothing at
all based on the movie he was a
liability in that car accident correct
he's hurt his arm dude Blindside good
action movie man yeah yeah
would you like that movie or no it
called I didn't know I thought the movie
was trash I wonder I'm trying to think
yeah I'm back on that because I do think
there's some oh we didn't talk about the
James Bond movies I don't like him he's
too small I'm not buying it what do you
mean he's too small come on yeah he's
too small Daniel Craig it's a small guy
he's fantastic it's like Tom Cruise
Mission Impossible too small nah Tom
Cruise is outstanding you're a critic on
movies yeah yeah when you're doing
specials
Shawshank Redemption say something
about that but I feel like that was
low-hanging fruit that you had in the
back pocket oh that's my favorite movie
give me five Once Upon a Time in
Hollywood phenomenal that's actually
number one for me okay what else uh
um see I like all that slower stuff man
I'm getting older Dad you're a bit Queen
Tarantino guy huge love him and glorious
bastards fantastic Reservoir Dogs yep
Pulp Fiction Dango oh man great movies I
didn't really I couldn't get on board
with Pulp Fiction really wow I might be
too young for it but it was oh man it
was one of those movies for me where I
was like I wanted to like it so much
because everybody you remember the
Christmas scene huh we hit the watch on
his ass is that the one with the gag
ball no you got it it's almost one
because Bruce Willis has no we can't
because I [__] up the show but bottom
line is Christopher Walken hid the watch
in his ass and gave to Bruce Willis as a
young kid that's why Bruce went back to
get his watch when when his wife you
know forget the watch yeah
what about machete machete
um
or what it is machete is uh you have to
give it it's it's due but I'm not gonna
put it in not top no my top picks up I I
have a soft spot for those goyer
over-the-top movies you like core stuff
love horse stuff me too big it depends
on I don't want to get I don't want to
just say yes to that because I'm not
like I don't go watch like
the shows and stuff like that my black
belt law and order Killers no not Law
and Order that's for a cup but um serial
kills I do have a weird thing about like
if they're you know you play the game
with people like if you could have lunch
with one with one person who would it be
Jeffrey Dahmer does go through my head
me too Charles Manson Charles Manson
Richard ramazzo be fun the YouTube
videos of him when they ask who are you
have you seen that video okay 45 he's
like nothing I'm nobody I'm a I'm a
boxcar a boy yeah man you're like kind
of like yo that's [__] I can see how
I would join the families back in the
70s yeah I get it they but I do like I
fell in love with like the old like
slasher movies like Friday the 13th I
love all that stuff Nightmare on Elm
Street I love that [__] me too I weren't
a big Halloween fan no I liked I liked
Halloween a lot but I was I was more on
Friday 13th yeah and throughout the last
couple of years did you fellas watch to
switch gears did you watch the Johnny
Manziel doc on Netflix I haven't I
haven't seen it I've only seen it it'll
frustrate you yeah the way they took
advantage of them it'll frustrate you
like the latest
series because they kind of jumped from
him he won
I think that Johnny Manziel was probably
a guy who had
struggles majorly with substance abuse
but was also an insanely talented
football player and so it sounded like
he would play football so he could
celebrate afterwards but he was living
for the celebration yeah and then you
will when you're an addict to that
Dimension you will orchestrate your life
any way you can you will self-destruct
in any way you can so that you have an
excuse to just go [__] crazy you need
self-sabotage a little bit and then he
got the NFL he's like oh I can't get
away with this right no no no but it's
too late your Baker Mayfield get out of
here you know is there is there anybody
who could be that you could never be a
quarterback without studying film and
being
hyper not at that life Kyle Murray
doesn't study film color Murray
calabari plays a game though you got the
reaction time for Call of Duty he's a
freak yeah he is a freak he's a freaking
he's his little beer it's crazy he has
one season left to pull it off but to go
back to the Johnny Manziel thing what a
wild time that was because that was the
same time as Manti Teo and the whole
girlfriend thing that until story was I
haven't seen that yet became friends
after that because I was sticking up for
him on here and then me and him started
DM who good guy man tile
oh Jack talk tie Jack talk tie very well
that's it when you're boys with him he
knew me for five years my my wife at the
time he's like
and I was like because and this is uh
this is my wife and I was like
you don't know my wife's name and he
goes I'm busy bro oh no five years at a
house party stuff man can you be a
little bit more you can only keep so
many up here I'm pretty bad with names
but not that bad not that bad you do you
do struggle with the names certain names
yeah
and don't go to them if you got if
you're having a down day if you're
having a down day whatever you do don't
go don't bring your sorrow here don't go
like this you'll go I get it man snap
out of it though tomorrow will be better
all right
all right buddy thanks a lot you'd be a
great therapist remember you're hitting
me up during a critical time in my life
too so he set me up for like hey look
and I'm never like that I'm just saying
I'm I'm also kind of Dead behind the
eyes but I was just I was all bunched up
and I was like finished it send me this
long text when we started talking
I started laughing so hard I was like
but that's how guys are I was like I was
like what am I doing then I even I
better help me way to go pal ironically
that helped me I was like yeah I'm being
a [__] and then it just made me laugh
because nothing can do you realize
there's nothing anybody can do like just
got to work hell yeah no one's coming to
save you yeah that's why I told him yeah
nobody's come and save you that's a
that's a little confident original and
you got it I don't know well it's Brian
well it's Brian count I know I'm a lot
older but yeah
you can text me thanks buddy will does
do a great job you might be good at it
he might be better Wills will Scott
Will's got many gifts but there's that
Johnny man there's that there's that
Johnny Manziel Dock and then they just
dropped I watched this morning I've been
up since four that Balco the Balco
documentary same The Untold doc same
thing Johnny Manziel who is it is it the
Jake Paul is that the dog that saved the
kids nope wouldn't watch that I wouldn't
watch steroids that's a good action
movie the steroid lab that was supplying
Barry Bonds everybody else it was a guy
who was behind like Marion Jones uh
that thing's just out forever right you
can't well that's not quite Hitler uh
it's Charlie Chaplin no chaplain had the
Hitler his is more like uh Waluigi yeah
he had a lab where people were all these
famous athletes were getting their their
stuff from would do but also baseball we
should probably bring them back right
yes
so exciting they looked great they look
jackassed the [__] arms on those guys
well you know what's interesting and I
actually damned them you know who
um was the guy behind all of it that
bringing this down is Jeff novitsky
who's the head of usada for the UFC the
golden snitch you're going I gave him
the name golden snitch for that reason
yep he'll find you yeah he'll find it
that's how they refer to him now for
real like they he gave him on Rogan he
called him the golden snitch and that is
if you look him up
I made t-shirts Chin's having a problem
because he can't spell that name and I
don't care I got approve for that Jeff
Nowitzki the way you pronounce some
words we just kind of got past t-shirts
a second ago yeah yeah
[__] love yo he's got a menacing look
it's gonna be tough it's the first thing
that pops up on you is that look
like that's what God gave you so just
own it look at him he looks like the
villain golden snitch right there but he
he went on Rogue and he he acknowledges
he's like should I give me that nickname
like I do what I do man I do I do what
do I do baby
but he's a scary dude because he got
into that you know because they are they
carry guns he's like the IRS but the the
branch that like if you see something
look into it and he just decides to
start looking into Barry Bonds and
Marion Jones and stuff Atlanta Armstrong
right America no that's what he looks
like yeah there you go Red Skull
I was like well that's tough for a
morning
I like going snitch
he does a little bit
man yeah that's tough dude that's the I
I just you saw the catches nobody these
days well
are people just not cheating now they're
they're always cheating well they're
just smarter when Jon Jones when Jon
Jones talking about oh they picked up on
pulses on little tiny details well they
caught the power slap guys why are you
testing them I want my power slap guys
on math code everything steroids all of
it it's like baseball let him go yeah
yeah they're in rash guard I do I will
go back to that and I will say you
should see it live it is a wild it's a
wild thing why haven't you seen a lot
can I see what you guys are doing here
and I like it I like it it's dude no I
would go
I'm
not loud you and Dana are you guys we're
fine I've given more compliments than
anything I promise we're fine he might
have an issue I feel like with Dana it's
you're fine and you're you're great or
you're not yeah I'm fine I have no
issues with him whatsoever If he if he
called me okay can you cover this
whatever he wants um would you yeah I
have no issue with it and you would go
and you feel that he bet yo this [__] is
kind of yeah maybe I quit knocking when
it first came out like me and the boys
the group chat was lit well yeah you see
that with a lot of UFC fighters like the
guys were around a little bit they're
like power slap what the [__] is this
but everyone I know who I respect is
like ah in person's pretty dope man and
like legit Fighters like I'm telling you
man I saw him train it's kind of I don't
say train but they said when you saw him
like slap each other around yeah yeah
they're like it's kind of dope and I was
like all right I would entertain it
seeing it live is is a very unique thing
would you ever do it no I've been killed
with a helmet on bro like imagine with
nothing I got this glass jaw I'm [__]
done you and me both brother yeah
but you see it live and it's fast-paced
like pull the guy off the mat next
person up they had them their entrance
music they come in these guys are the
cool thing about it is it's starting to
get to a point where like more people
are finding interest in it and there's
like bigger stronger guys coming in and
it's like there's some [__] loud hits
you got cats out there you're going for
ten thousand dollars like one dude was
like I'm trying to buy my wife a pair of
tits Wolverine I think that yeah that's
all I remember him yeah yeah red beard
he said if he wins these guys
tits God bless we're talking about it
when we was doing fight companion with a
rampage Rampage is like back then when
you were not like making a lot of money
like would you go slap or be slap for oh
yeah I said no thousands of dollars but
Rampage was like I mean if this is
before the all the fighting like the
little money I think he was making
overseas at the time for sure yeah I get
it like when it first came out I was
like I think because Dana's behind it
and the other I think the reason why he
got so much hate on it just from the
outside looking in is because they use
the UFC platform to push it and people
like bro we're here for the UFC not for
the slap fight and he kept pushing it so
that turned people off I think if he
would just promote on his own and not
the UFC it would have gone over much
better but she's like the reason this
guy I mean you're trying to he's playing
I completely yeah yeah no I have no
issue correct me if I'm wrong UFC was
getting horrible reviews when it first
started oh yeah you're talking about
1993. I'm saying it went through this
for a while it is yeah it just keeps me
no sure yeah people took like you know
dick chain and stuff said his
cockfighting but that yeah it's still
drama candy yeah that's right it's still
real fighting yeah yeah slap fighting
Tufts I understand the difference yeah I
absolutely I'm not going to say it is
when you see it on a screen it is
absolutely insane you're like yo this is
I knew they were onto some because my
wife I turned on like look at this
[__] expecting to make fun of it and
then we're both like she's laughing
she's like I can't get enough of this
look at these days well it's like it's
so well-consumed stuff yeah it's so
barbaric yeah I don't like that Loki
brings it out of you too when you're
watching like I'll Stand in there slap
the [__] out of him really yeah
I just don't like seeing him getting
knocked out like that because it's just
like the somebody's getting knocked out
and so that looks more like spectacle
not sport right so it's like oh that guy
has to do that I love that TBS but also
Brian like think about the times when
you're young and you're really drunk and
you got that one white friend that's
like hey somebody slapped me yeah and
you're like okay let's [__] watch
always the white friend yeah it's always
a wife it's always the weird white guys
you kind of like circle around you like
hey can I slap you yeah yeah do you ever
do slap fighting in high school you'll
be like boxing but you just like slap
each other yeah I had to do a [__]
commercial where this girl kept slapping
me and it was and I would just I would
try to time it and just go with it and
stuff but after a while remember when he
slapped me we're doing that bit out here
yep for that commercial that [__]
hurt yeah I know it does yeah that [__]
isn't because you can really wind up man
those boys are going for it yeah I just
went I just kind of caught you but I'm a
martial artist true
how much do you train what who trains
more now why don't I train when don't I
train
uh yeah do you keep your I looked at him
one time he was
yeah yeah what does roll mean
do you think will it have a shot with
you no no bro who we've done it I
believe I know you hide me up and I do
appreciate it like I love it yeah but
are you [__] you train me no okay
he's from Montana a few times
used to being so big I put my body on
people and they end up getting tired
will like hip talks me a couple of times
I wrestle growing up but I'm saying like
[__] would piss me off we all know how
different when the guy was that athletic
who also wrestled you he's not hearing a
peep out of you but not not with that
he's a gorilla it's just a different
language that's all I did like we'd have
NFL guys come in all the time yeah yeah
I I always tell them hey I always tell
him he's like I will I always tell the
story of a black belt there was a black
belt I watched fight over here my life
with this [__] microphone
my nuts just keep going inside me during
this what's he doing it's not a
competition Bro you've got around too
much with it all this is my War you guys
keep talking this is my I watched I
watch shop take real famous you know
professional fighters and do some crazy
[__] to him right quickly so I remember
watching that and I he was bigger so I
went okay but it was the first time I
saw like his skill set because he wasn't
using strength he was using skill but
then I knew who his teachers were and I
knew how he came up he he really learned
from
like the best of the best and worked on
base like it's so it's very different
and it was his job so you're talking
about a guy who was training all the
remember we're in San Francisco in that
very famous guy hurt you yeah then I
yeah there was like oh really I got I
got [__] steamrolled by a famous dude
but he's famous black belt like high
level yeah
high level great guy I love him he
didn't he didn't know who I was and he
didn't want me to get positioned on him
and talk about on a podcast so he goes
oh you want to roll with us like you
want to roll with a pro watch this and
he just he just like I mean for real
like I've never [__] Helen up I was
watching like that the [__] and he even
tried making a point out yeah in front
of all the students I was like and he
goes and he was like oh I don't like
that because Brian's old and Brian's
also not a female fighter yeah and
Brian's just a high school wrestler and
yeah it's also my boy and it's funny it
was embarrassing I mean yeah Brian Shock
you shock you with his athleticism makes
56 he can climb a rope it doesn't matter
you know what I mean he's got crazy
endurance he can't going and he'll keep
coming back and and he's a great mimic
but the point is this guy really [__]
up in front of everybody
goes You Wanna he goes you want to roll
right after I go hey over here
I won I winked at him but I watched
Brandon do to him what he did to me way
worse and I went oh oh my God like but I
mean hey like that I rang and I was like
oh oh Jesus Christ I saw him turn it up
and then the best was after he had done
all but then he started rolling real
nice with everybody rolling real nice to
everybody he's just rolling let you get
position he's going to let you do stuff
you know and all that and then this
professional fighter hold up we were
done we were walking off the mat like
hey you guys yes this was the best
professional fighter Samoan 300 pounds
and when you think about a Simone a
Simone who trains who's a black look
like Moana who's a black belt and a pro
fighter demigod and still fighting by
the way still fighting okay so he goes
schaab
and I was like oh no I know that guy's
you know that guy guys he waited till I
was in a different event different
League oh no and I went and shot and I
go I go I probably go dude that's a
giant Samoan and he's a black belt and
chop goes and it doesn't matter oh [__]
and I go what and then I watched my the
Anaconda with them long Bam Bam arms
just get in there with them and [__]
torture that guy torture that black belt
Samoan 300 pounds and I went I got it
okay that's what happens yeah yeah yeah
yeah what's up Daddy it's a different
it's a it's a different level but you
but if you want to do it grab them well
that's that leads us to you see Bradley
Martin Mighty Mouse
yeah yeah what's going on my boy Bradley
Martin he's like 260 pounds like yeah oh
bodied up yeah boys yeah own Zoo culture
great job stud great guy athletic you
know jumps through the roof but we I was
on his pod and he's saying he could beat
up any like 135 or under in the world I
was like oh no Bubba have you ever seen
DJ yeah that's kind of his thing though
right I've never really seen a show but
that's kind of start off
it's a bit Yeah so then it got real with
Mighty must say nah kill him like no
dude so I hit up Mighty Mouse like yo
this dude he's like I saw it I'm down so
in September they're coming here to
Grapple here oh that's gonna be awesome
well Rob the mat that'll be awesome
You're Gonna Roll some mats in the
office we have mats in the office yeah
you guys gotta roll around a little bit
dude
let's forget it for the Vlog
can I have a question eight inches all
right
it's not true when you sat there I
believe you were there too with Rogan
and Rogan gave you that essentially best
friend talk in front of so many people
because I sat there like this Doug like
what remember I had he was back in Jiu
Jitsu yeah and he goes radio silent when
I get [__]
are you Switzerland yeah are you
Switzerland you just Mr neutral oh is it
because the way I mean he speaks so well
and he did it in a very respectful way
even because he loves you yeah how did
you on the receiving end in the
beginning how did that how did you
handle that I I can only imagine watch
it on the bus and episode I was super oh
really yeah when he came on yeah it was
just you two years when I was in Camp
yeah I was super bad I was really upset
yeah and then at the time because you're
like sitting there probably like boiling
but no one lives
Brian and him to his credit because Joe
said you know dude we got done we don't
have to run it we don't have to run this
I know that's a shot
you're like no I don't yeah but but Joe
gave us now Joe goes if you don't want
to run it you know we don't have to run
it and and Shop went [__] it it's the
truth run it it's what happened I mean
that was the biggest thing he made when
you said that legit got goosebumps
because it is that was the biggest
decision he made I remember when he said
that he goes he goes nah man this is the
truth this is my life this is what I'm
dealing with this is what it's like to
be a fighter run it that decision might
have been the biggest decision we made
yeah
why hide anything when people come up to
me after all these years they go I feel
like I know you I go well you kind of do
know me yeah I don't know if I have that
many Secrets bro it is who I am still
live your life that way too that episode
that episode was supposed to be firing
the kid right so we're driving our
studio and Brian called and goes dude
Rogan wants to do it with us I was like
what and I was like no we're doing
firing kid he's like no we'll do fine
kids but we're gonna use Rogan studio so
that episode's not a JRE episode that's
actually a fighter in the kid right but
we just did it from Roman Studio that's
right I remember we were driving over I
called Brian like hey man make sure this
isn't like an intervention type thing
and Brian's like I would never see you
there you said you said to me in person
you go you said to me in person you go
just I don't I didn't want to talk about
the fight don't let him don't let him
like uh tell me not to fight anymore and
so I don't want to I don't want to get
into that because I already knew I but
and but I didn't know what in hindsight
like before I even walked out to that
fight against Travis Brown I looked at
my corner last one boys oh breathe it in
last one I'm not doing this anymore I'm
sick of this [__] last well Rogan said
to me as he walked after you got beat by
Travis Brown as Joe walked out of the
ring out of he after he's an interview
on Travis he walked by me I was like he
literally walked by me and he goes like
this he goes he needs to retire
like he's gonna get hurt and that's what
he said he goes the good news is he
didn't get hurt but he needs because he
could see that Brennan had one foot and
one foot out you can't do that in the
Octagon yeah you can't do that you can't
do that any professional sport no not
that level either the dogs I was
fighting too will can he's that talented
but I'm saying I I I do think the
separation octagon the dogs I was
fighting too like the level I was at
like I'm not getting newcomers like they
were throwing me some dogs man
I was making money doing this and on the
way over there you're like I don't want
him to tell me no I was like yeah I
don't want to do this and they went
straight there and you're off the bat
brother and that's why I started crying
like I was so mad dude [__] I bet how
long after did you go from like being
angry to almost having peace with all of
it what's today oh I'm still upset are
you really still upset no I'm not no I'm
just kidding not upset me and Ruby have
talked about it no I think it's good you
have friends like that but then also
Rogan was also the guy who like even
before I thought about every time I was
like can you do stand-up man you're
[__] funny I'm telling you just jump
in there get knocked you can do this and
so when somebody believes in you like
that I was like well [__] that dude's
been doing stuff for 30 years and
kellen's like dude dude stand up get a
stand up I was like you think my dumb
ass like yeah dude we we've seen you
tell stories get into it so pushing me
that way so that they've helped with all
that tremendously seems like you and
will have uh similar stories in the
sense of like you're both doing
something
at the highest level and then finding
something else and made an easy pivot
like a seamless transition from one I
guess it seems seamless it's been work
man yeah it is absolutely it's been a
piece to have the level of success you
did from right from UFC to getting in
the situation being super blessed to
help with Joe doing the fighter and the
kid running this studio yeah I think
it's time in the outside it's like it's
admirable I appreciate it thank you but
I also think this is
timing well I always say too though that
you the kind of person that you are like
when you're a certain kind of person and
you come to the table
as your complete self with all your
stuff which is what he'll do and you
know people recognize it and and people
like you and when people like you you
get opportunities or you you they bring
you into their world and and there's an
intimate look and all of a sudden you go
maybe I can do this too so I always
wonder about that I always wonder if
success like like guys like you for
example like you are going to be
successful at anything you did whether
it was football or anything I feel like
you were going to correct everybody in
this room like for me you know
like anything I was gonna do I couldn't
stand not finding my I wanted to be the
one I wanted to be with the cool kids I
wanted to be good at it I just couldn't
bear to be sitting on the bench in life
you know what I didn't realize though
because in sports I didn't have this
like in the UFC I didn't have this
because it's pretty black and white but
in stand up I thought
I didn't realize the hate I'd get
because that makes it from the
opportunities like to me it was and it's
like when people hate it on CM Punk I
was like you wouldn't do it like you
wouldn't jump to the friendly queue if
they're offering you two million dollars
a fight in the UFC like everyone would
hate on CM Punk and I was like who gives
a [__] like they're giving the
opportunity you wouldn't do it so for me
I didn't realize the hate I get from
other Comics because of some of the
operations he gets a lot of hate now
sure different but it was just I I
didn't expect that because in sports
like we support each other like [__]
yeah like when when I knew will had a
athletic background he did too I'm like
those are my guys like when any when any
fighter gets in a podcast I'm like what
can I do how can I help you kami's a
little different it's a little different
because it's like a it's like a crab
mentality a little bit yeah it doesn't
and I didn't expect that because I'm and
also like when the pandemic hit and you
know some some of our buddies got canned
stuff like that I'm like rally the
troops boys let's rally up let's fight
against them
where's everybody what the [__] are we
doing where's the Boys At
like no that's how we work you can see
that's how we operate yeah
that was a unique world that was kind of
like
taking everything by storm when Rogan
and I were doing not yeah when we first
did his mediator
um what'd you say Joe Rogan's a friend
of mine when we were doing a meat eater
the first episode we ever did you can
see it on camera
um my my good friend Joe Rogan had a lot
of meals together he we we we get to we
get there and Rogan on camera goes we're
about to go hunting it's our first time
and Rogan says to me he goes dude
pressure's on us I go why he goes we're
representing Comics we're representing
our community and I go oh yeah you know
that unified bunch and he just burst out
laughing because it's it's it's not it's
not coming from Sports it's not a
community like you could call me like
hey bro a guest canceled I need you to
fly here on Tuesday I'm like all right
say less dog I'm there it's just not
that way in comedy it breaks my heart
but now I know it's not that way and
it's not necessarily it's not like
Sports is King although I do think
Sports is sports is Kim um but yeah you
don't come up from a background of sport
or like a discipline even like you know
fighting MMA jiu
jitsues yeah like through some [__]
having to embrace a suck with people
like it's it's very much more of an
individualized yeah like industry stand
up you're up there alone you're up there
in a lot of comics it's like they have
their backgrounds that allow them to be
as funny as they are right so they're
like dealing with all this different
[__] and baggage that it's not like they
were ever in
um you know I guess like the sport world
to where you're embracing like any type
of locker room mentality I I I think for
sure football's the ultimate team sport
so you guys learn how to give and take I
think football's the best social
intelligence is huge in the football
Community every time I meet a football
player I'm just amazed their social
intelligence their ability to be self uh
defacing and also be super funny that
then that comes from locker room he
hears in the locker room if you're not
able to take a ribbing and give it out
you're probably gonna [__] some
people be trying to write stuff like the
Northwestern kids yeah yeah exactly
there's so many unique Personalities in
the locker room because you have those
dudes that are just overly talented and
won't take like won't be able to have
that yeah but then you have this like
specific position groups for me off it's
a line like those dudes all day every
day just hang out it's the best it's the
best and it's also like the different
backgrounds like my boys in college like
Lawrence Vickers was from the Fifth Ward
in Houston like hood hood gangster so
his family would come so it's like
dealing with that energy then you have
this kid over here from Wyoming and if
you know so and you're all friends you
all have one comment goal like it didn't
matter your background black white asian
we don't give a flying [__] can you ball
man yeah that's all it is in the times
where I've never met an Asian in
football but I was trying to there's one
there's a kicker I was trying to like
yeah but I'm with you on that
yeah but it's almost like and even when
those moments arise
you got to get over it yeah you got to
figure it out so that doesn't matter so
we're not as Delta guy uh who's just
been out for a year and he's like the
guy oh well well there you go hold on
they both ended up loving him yeah he's
my boy yeah every time you say Delta I
think about me trying to [__] yeah but
Brian gets rock hard yeah Brian gets
rock hard anyone's like other than
special force Brands like go on tell me
stories I'm a gay man but if it's
illegally like Delta like Delta like an
assaulter he was cool and uh but he was
talking about how when the reason they
stay so Elite is because when they go on
Mission and they come back they sit
around a room and they basically they're
they're super honest with each other
like they're like you [__] up on that
you [__] up on that accountability
what can we do that's different how can
we try other [__] and they're always
innovating with different like stuff I
don't know how that has anything to do
with what we're talking about I don't
know
the comedy dude but going back to the
comedy everyone just kind of disperse
and stuff like that it's weird being on
the outside and being able to be around
comics like y'all Comics like Chrysler
and sagura and uh de Stefano and these
guys because it seems like it doesn't
seem that way like everyone's out for
themselves
it's great
are boys like Chrysler crisis very thick
alcoholic mother like I love Bert I love
him Schulte those are my guys it's more
the the la thing I was just surprised it
it's all good it's a doggy dog it's a
dog it's Hollywood Hollywood and
everyone's gonna be fine
it's an individual thing first of all it
has to be more of them you're traveling
a lot and and there's a sometimes the
window to what you can get so it just is
what it is it's an individual practice
it's a stand-up favors sometimes people
that are a lot of times rather
individualistic maybe maybe that's
better better way
too what's that it's Gotta Be Still hard
not to steal people's [__] that's uh
that's going back to YouTube no I have
to watch because Loki I don't want to
like infiltrate my mind especially the
same premises I'm out yeah it's like you
want to see NBA I mean you're doing a
little standout
people just tell you that when you come
to town okay Josh Wolf had me do anytime
he goes he has like a basically a rookie
he takes like a virgin out there and
they have to do five minutes and they
bring you next time they want they help
you punch up and then you got to go out
and do it again but one time Josh Wolf
came to town he wanted me to do stand up
so I went out there and did stand up for
five less like 10 minutes and uh that's
rare and uh I thought he did I thought
it was funny that's where that comes
from and Steve Byrne he loved it he's
like man you know all this different
stuff Steve Burn the greatest guy dude
he is the nicest guy by the way yeah
well that's how I know the difference
then that's how you should have led
yeah but it was like I know and I know I
was here I went and watched the film
right I watched him I took the coaching
I'm gonna be better for that but it also
took away from the Johnny Knox but Steve
is such an incredible human being
back that story the only person I've
ever been in the same room with I'm like
I gotta get a pick I have to and I was
like how am I gonna do it and then he
came up to me I was like man you think
this guy really has a chance I was like
I holy [__] it was Drake oh she's
working for showtime for the Floyd
um Conor fight and I was like the MMA
expert for Connor so I'm gonna suit and
tie getting ready to go on stage and I
was like oh [__] we're in Toronto doing
the press conference and it's not wild
it was the first day wild sold out Arena
and I'm like man this is crazy I see
Drake I'm like holy [__] that's Drizzy
Drake run through the six and I was like
I got to get a picture yes [__] he's
my favorite and I was all nervous and
then I hear out of the corner anything
kind of really has a chance man I heard
you talking all that [__] I was like
yeah check holy [__] what up dog I need
a picture he's like yeah no doubt it's
like oh [__] yeah but you're also there
where Will Smith and Robert Downey Jr
came running I didn't ask them for a
picture yeah but they were like oh it's
the hybrid and they wanted to talk to
you yeah yeah Robert Downey was like
throwing front kicks at me like very
cool man
that's when you need that like a
producer you need somebody
you know what that party took all our
phones it was an Oscar party and
everyone's in tuxedos so no there's no
cell phones I've been to those parties
and Will Smith asked me to uh Will Smith
asked me if I did private training
you're the reason why Chris Rock no I
didn't train with him I didn't take him
up on it I got different Vibes what did
you say to him no I'm gonna hold myths
for you you didn't say no I promise you
I was a guy well at the time as a
current UFC fight I'm like oh I don't I
don't like hold mids dog if you want to
put me in [__] we like whatever's the
[__] I Am Legend three I mean but I
don't hold meds daddy you get there he's
got a latex mask on you oh [__] I didn't
plan on this you're gonna be a zombie
can you go that's the five I go yeah hey
back to throwing Steve Burn flowers yeah
he's the man he's just an incredible
human being he calls me up one of the
few guys will be like just checking up
Bonnie I love you buddy dude he was
doing a show I was doing uh San Jose
Improv I don't know him that well and uh
after I get off stage and after like hey
uh do you know Steve Brown like I don't
know who Steve is like he's here man
everyone's freaking out I'm like okay
cool like he wants to talk to you I'm
like oh [__] I wonder what happened he's
like hey man watch your set loved it
give me some like punch lines I was like
just wanted to see your set man keep
doing what you're doing dude
good energy he's and I'm sitting there
thinking like Steve you helped me put
together some of these jokes and you're
just sitting here giving me all this
credit it's great he's just like the
nicest human being in the world he's a
real one he's one of the good guys yes
he's a great guy I love him I love him
you guys too though all right listen you
guys doing all right we do our thing you
guys rip dude no no legit boys you guys
like when Taylor was talking about when
we were putting the idea together and
everything else I've literally the
fighter and the kid and whenever I get
home I'll [__] send you guys we're
getting a nice little group chat we'll
call it the boys I like that that makes
me feel good and you guys are written in
the journal with others that inspired
all of it you're you're a blueprint
you're an athlete that turned into media
I've legitimately shout out my boy Kenny
Farkas two thousand how long you guys
been doing it 2001 12 years now 2012
2011. 2014. I think I'm riding I'm
driving back with with my boy Kenny
Farkas we're on our way back from
wherever and he's like do you know uh
have you ever listened to fighter in the
kid because I had just started to like
bro you ever heard of podcasts and uh
he's like man my favorite one's the
fighter and the kid and we're listening
to you guys the whole way back so the
fact that we are sitting here right now
is insane that's so awesome and now you
guys are bigger and you guys are you
guys are overnight
900 and something episodes right oh yeah
we're over way over that yeah because
that's not counting the days in Brian's
Garage the fox episodes where I mean but
the fact that you guys are [__] still
still alive still doing it yeah I know
still doing it and crushing it thanks
and when you came through Nashville
you know no no no keep going keep going
when you came through Nashville and
Taylor's in training camp and we get to
I get to get you one I remember like
telling them hey man [__] Shops
coming on dude I remember I was mad I
know that's right you went there that's
right I said fomo at the ass I was like
but Lily McAfee we're talking to McAfee
and he's like look if you're gonna do it
be consistent like because we're only
going to take it until training camp and
then stop it because we didn't want to
interface that was always my advice and
he's like man you gotta [__] you
gotta backlog it's like a job brother
it's a job when we had Chandler on and
uh he's like yeah let's shoot a video to
shop and I'm kind of thinking [__] I
don't want to do that and he said hey
man and you're like champ absolutely
well I come in in a you know next couple
weeks or whatever yeah you come on and
it's just like it's insane that this is
all [__] the fighter and the kids we
love it the fighter and the [__] kid
and the boys were sitting here we're
able to and legitimately inspired by
somebody like your guys's work no he was
an athlete to Media you guys being a Duo
like when we're getting our chairs and
couch set up it's from the set of the
fighter and the kids you guys have way
better chairs than us that's awesome and
I remember when I realized I mean I knew
you were talented yeah man I knew your
talented on the companion those aren't
easy to do and you [__] ran with that
thing when jelly backed out I was a
little nervous I was like [__] man like
number one Rampage Jackson I'm like
nervous being around him because I had
his Affliction shirt when I was a young
buck sure and knew you but I'm like man
jelly would have helped like because I
know jelly Jelly's the man how bad is
jelly crushing it bro
Arenas we were talking about like Steve
like he's another good guy when jelly
first uh the we met jelly the day you
came on with Theo on and then I brought
jelly there jelly was in Jake and jelly
goes man I love bustling the Bros and he
Joe's been my boy way before he blew up
and I go come with me he goes no he
thinks he'll have me on I'm like at
least come meet him and then after that
get their number yes like you think
they'll have me I'm like yeah dude I
know they're my guys I forced jelly to
come with me and push them on you guys
yeah when we first started I was
literally like getting like my some
tires put on my truck at this place and
this dude said hey you should get this
this white wrapper on named Jelly Roll
and I thought I I don't really listen to
rap like that especially white yeah I'm
thinking
it was a it was a pass and I was like it
was like passing by like I don't know
man and we were like not really doing
anything we were Loki looking for guests
I was like I don't know about that ball
if it fits because you just don't know
what to expect
here and then when he came with y'all he
left a lasting impression that like just
literally elevator pitch of being like
hey like you guys but he's electric said
all this stuff he's a Titans fan I was
like this dude's [__] awesome yeah
man and literally when that Hulu
documentary came out about his people
need to go see it dude it's [__]
unbelievable I sat there in my room by
myself and watched it in the first 15
minutes I was in tears because there's
there is not a better feeling than
becoming friends with somebody watching
them chase a dream and then succeeding
that dream and being
just being like I'm here to support you
I'm only in tears just watching this man
do his thing and know what he came from
with all the stories
jelly salt of the earth not to flex like
Brian's done on the Pod but jelly texted
me yesterday like love you brother out
of nowhere
takes me out of nowhere love you brother
thinking of you yeah like aren't you
[__] like selling out Staples or some
[__] yeah dude he's massive man and
you're right you're right and I'll jump
on board I'll name drop a jelly roll too
um I texted him the other day asked for
tickets to the his St Louis show just
for my friends I was like hey you can
tell me to [__] off he's like dude list
for life you have yep whatever you want
we were thinking like I literally texted
him yesterday said the same thing for
people in Arizona and I literally text
the person back like he like jelly
that's phenomenal as he is he's gotten
worse at texting back yeah you see his
phone it's like 1500 well he wakes up at
3 P.M I'm actually I'm actually having
lunch with him in three minutes he hit
me back in three minutes I think he's
FaceTiming me he texted me back in three
minutes he's like anything you need same
thing tickets for life well it's good to
know that because my brother needs
tickets when he's in them everybody
and he talks about all that stuff he's
like I'd much rather do this [__] than
all the the corporate stuff but all the
fans that you have back home everywhere
else everybody's like man I've started
listening to jelly since he's been on
this yeah man and he just builds it when
he was on American Idol I'm a huge
American Idol fan right when he was on
there I'm like hold this dude made it
dude holy [__] that's why I was like
holy [__] he's mainstream he did we did
like a charity softball event and it was
right after he did Rogan and I was like
how was it dude like what was the bump
really like he's like dude like still
now it's been a week and a half and I'm
getting the numbers are going crazy I
can't believe you guys haven't been on
Rogan yet it's a long play hey hey you
have so many mutual friends you know
what guys everything we've heard it's
got to like you know to like it has to
be natural again
when we when we met him uh with Shane at
the Mirage there was definitely like he
walked in the room and you're it's it's
Rogan dude like but you're trying to
like handle it the guy was so [__]
Down to Earth had a conversation and
he's he's exactly what you see yeah like
yeah and he picks up on [__] If he
if he looks he can look at you and be
like oh that looks like a a good person
he's the best of all time at it if you
come out of him as a character or
something he'll go like this who is that
guy and he'll just literally let him go
get him out of here like a like a roll
the way the way for a male rolls shots
he'll just be like
we know the guy your guys are freaking
out I think they're saying you guys
gotta get going this is the [__]
fellas we [__] like
the energy I have as much energy more
energy than from when we started well
you know why you have energy why magic
mine that's what it is it's the magic I
thought it was the Twisted Tea
I love iced tea and I like a Twist to it
but I've never had it if you're gonna
like you're gonna like as long as it
goes well with ice that's that's me and
Drake not a big deal yeah that's a good
thing that needs to be the [__]
that's all right for this episode
talking about the um
with the Bros
and and Drake this has been Chris yeah
we love you guys it's literally the
first time yeah yeah I know I guess no
what are you gonna say though I was
gonna say the first time because I
obviously follow all your guys's [__] it
was like you were saying busting the bro
us Will Compton this Superstar [__]
linebacker I'm thinking this dude has no
[__] thing
he's just shooting from the hip
oh
great time I wish you could have been
like five more hours me too man you boys
got [__] to do though companion we gotta
lock in and we can't be the fight
whoever runs the socials who who's
damning me oh that was probably Tom I
run it now
four days in advance it's four days in
advance
we'll get going [__] all right boys we
love you man yeah